welcome to the TEL show we've got a
wonderful hilarious guest this week
we're really excited lamorne Morris he's
an actor and comedian he plays Winston
Bishop on new girl and he's also in
barbershop the next cut which is out
this week so here on the on the tell
show lamorne we always try to open up
with a game of never have I ever each of
us will say something that we've never
done and then if you have done it like
if I'm like I've never killed someone
and Isaac's like of course I have well
he will wring him out and then you'll
talk about it I guess are would never
have I ever auditioned for a television
show I auditioned 15 times for new girl
wait what it was crazy - for the role of
coach originally I got offered the part
couldn't do it because the same day CBS
offered me a role the new girl when I
turned down the role they ended up
offering it to Damon Wayans Jr they
weren't anticipating that his show happy
endings was getting picked up for a
second season so yeah this is like this
is like street fight stuff yeah and so
because he left that left a space open
for another character and so they came
up the character Winston and in doing so
they had to audition 11 more times so
you got you auditioned a normal amount
of times the first time got the part
yes and then because of all that
kerfuffle you then had to come in and
then that was 11 more time yes it was a
nightmare indeed but it was fun
it's like we built up chemistry with the
cast already it was it was literally a
first-name basis when you walk in
Lemoore what's up oh hey Jake he's
always going on and I knew that they
liked me because they've treated me
differently you know after working out
the room and until you walk by and go
that wasn't oh my god yes
which is directedness to me what do you
got summer in uh never have I ever stood
someone up okay here's the story I was
living in San Francisco at the time in a
one-bedroom with like four other people
and like pigeons in the walls and like
mice that I'm like friends with and like
eating cereal basically I had worked my
butt off to get this job at this bar and
at that time an old friend of mine from
college had moved down and he started
working at this company called Facebook
mmm and so my buddy his name's Mike my
buddy Mike kind of calls me up he's like
look we're really staffing up right now
we're really growing I was like I heard
I was like that's four college kids and
my reply to Mike was you know I really
worked hard to get this job at this bar
I kind of feel like it's things are
starting to turn around for me
I feel like Facebook you never know if
that's going anywhere that's for kids
that's college stuff and I really
appreciate the opportunities like look
here's the meeting here's the time just
calm he didn't get though it should note
that Mike now owns a house on top of
vernel Hill in San Francisco he yeah I
was one of his groomsmen he flew me out
and bought me a thousand dollar suit for
his wedding I think he's looking at
another house oh you shut up Mark
Zuckerberg mark was waiting with a
clipboard the way oh I love this guy so
much I just want to check the right box
yeah I just want to give him like lots
of options it's gonna be the one oh I
like good wave looking at my way that I
can still get out of bed every morning
knowing that I just like like took that
wrong of a choice in my life is I was
just like with that much money I'd be
dead oh yeah like there would've been a
boat accident so we continued in the
game yeah now you got your have
something you've never done
never have I ever made out with a
co-worker of mine
what do you apply I'm implying I feel
like if y'all hosted show together that
at some point some penetration is going
on oh I don't know I don't know oh
I made out with a co-worker but not at
my current job I worked at a bookstore
for like seven years of my early 20s and
20 to 27 the only people I hooked up
with were my co-workers dirty yes I mean
there was a lot of sex that happened at
the bookstore assume that's true that is
true your holiday parties were I slept
with my boss yeah
I want to be that Boston it's like God
[ __ ] all my employees where do you work
a four-shot no a bookstore yeah I mean
there was like it was a wet there was a
web of like sexual misconduct happening
at that bookstore book people Austin
Texas wow you just shot him out great
place I want to be clear great place to
buy yeah great place to buy there so if
I went in to book in Austin Texas I
might be standing in the wet spot beats
me to ten years but you know I'm gonna
go in there with the black lights yeah
poor puppy poop I think they're gonna be
great for their business or really bad
you know I would definitely go there